Der august ist der monat der
sternschnuppen und wenn er noch ein paar wünsche frei habt dann schaut unbedingt an diesem wochenende in den himmel ihr wisst ja wenn man
eine sternschnuppe sieht dann darf man sich was wünschen denn
jetzt im august erreicht der perseidenstrom seinen höhepunkten zwar ist an diesem wochenende denn es wird wohl bis zu 100 sternschnuppen pro stunde
regnen das tolle ist sie sind in diesem jahr besonders gut zu sehen
das liegt auch am mond wann und wo die sternstunden zu beobachten sind und noch viel mehr jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Vor allem von sonntag auf montag 12 bis 13 august werden ganze schwärme am himmel aufblitzen die perseiden
kommen von dem kometen 109p
swift tafel der die sonne alle 133 jahre umkreis jährlich nämlich am 12 august kreuzt und seine
drecks spur also der kometenstaub den er im weltall hinterlässt diese nacht kann man sich als sterngucker also in jedem jahr dick im kalender
markieren der komet wurde 1862 entdeckt und seine umlaufbahn um die sonne braucht eben 130 ja mit
252 1000 kilometern pro stunde trinkt sein kometenstaub in die lufthülle der erde ein die luft erhitzt sich auf mehr als
3000 grad denn der partikelstrom presst sie so stark zusammen die perseiden gehören zu den schnellsten
sternschnuppen überhaupt sternschnuppen entstehen ja wenn die erde durch diese trümmerwolke der des kometen fliegt
und die kometen partikel die dann in die atmosphäre gelangen sind etwa so klein wie ein stecknadelkopf
und dabei verglühen diese
stecknadelköpfe
spektakulär die perseiden sind schon seit mitte juli unterwegs und werden das auch noch
rund anderthalb wochen seien nämlich bis zum 24 august von sonntag auf montag können es bis zu 100 sternschnuppen
pro stunde sein und das ist das absolute traditionelle maximum in den tagen vorher und nachher
flitzen aber auch immerhin noch bis zu 50 sternschnuppen pro stunde über das firmament dass der media schauer der personen besonders
gigantisch ist liegt übrigens daran dass der komet schon so oft um die sonne gekreist ist dabei hat er mehr als nur eine spur hinterlassen
und die sorgen dafür diese spuren das wäre besonders viele sternschnuppen über so einen langen zeitraum hinweg beobachten können fachleute
rechnen sogar damit dass auch einige besonders helle lichtkugeln dabei sein werden diese boliden können in ihrer lichtstarke sogar den mond übertreffen
ja wie auch schon beim blutmond vor zwei wochen empfiehlt es sich den
sternschnuppen regen an einem möglichst dunklen ort zu verfolgen also am besten weit weg von hellen lichtquellen die
beste zeit für die beobachtungen sind die späten abendstunden und die frühen morgenstunden das maximum der perseiden beginnt
2018 am 12 august ab 22 uhr abends und
dauert die ganze nacht ab etwa halb fünf morgens wird es dann etwas zu hell sein um sie gut
beobachten zu können super für alle sternschnuppen fans ist das mondlicht in diesem jahr denn seine dünne sich die geht schon 21 30 unter
wichtig ist dann ein platz mit freier sicht nach nordost aber insgesamt solltet ihr den ganzen himmel im blick haben wenn die perseiden
flitzen weit über den sternenhimmel
manche treten auch erst im
südwesten in die atmosphäre
ein falls ihr fotografieren wollte braucht ihr echt ein bisschen zeit und geduld er das gut klappen wird den sternstunden können bis zu 70 kilometer
pro sekunde
damit super schnell sein das sind
252 1000 kilometer pro stunde
wo auch ja wenn ihr kein video dazu untereinander dem verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht denn die etwas
unzulässiger boxee auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video hat war hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social and media abonnieren
dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken kam leben von kometen auf die erde bis dann
bleibt dran